cinéma avec la sortie du premier film
sur les attentats du 11-septembre vol 93
raconte le courage de ses passagers qui
ont tenté de prendre le contrôle de
l'avion qui s'est écrasé en pennsylvanie
une reconstitution qui se veut très
réaliste parce qu'elle deschamps raimu
poissonnier leur avion a été détourné de
cuisine demi heure lorsque les passagers
du vol 93 apprennent ce qui s'est passé
à new york
il faut la tempe et à partir de leurs
appels de leurs messages le film montre
en temps réel comment ils ont tenté de
prendre le contrôle de l'appareil
on y va
quarante passagers livrés à eux mêmes et
au sol la pagaille absolue dans vol 93
pence line y joue son propre rôle mais à
toi pour savoir ce qui se passe ce matin
du 11 septembre ce responsable du
contrôle aérien a vécu le plus grand
drame mais aussi le plus grand échec de
sa vie
c'est pas vrai vous avez vu ce qui est
arrivé
c'était le chaos famille moi ce fut une
terrible frustration de ne pas savoir ce
qui se passait on s'est contenté de
subir de réagir sans rien contrôler
quand vous êtes contrôleurs aériens la
dernière chose que vous voulez faire
c'est vous contenter de réagir
loin de tout sensationnalisme paul
greengrass a voulu nous replonger dans
l'événement parce que dit-il nous n'en
avons pas encore tiré les leçons
problème le problème de la colère le
problème de l'engagement des musulmans
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
si nous voulons vraiment nous y
confronter cela demande des changements
profonds dans nos sociétés sont le monde
ne veut pas on préfère s'occuper de la
coupe du monde ou des vacances consultez
dès la préparation du film les familles
des passagers ont apporté un soutien
sans réserve vol 93 est un grand film à
10,1 critiques américains résumant ainsi
le sentiment général et j'en ai détesté
chaque seconde